beijing es desde hoy la primera ciudad
del mundo que organiza juegos olímpicos
de verano y de invierno los segundos
llegan en las peores condiciones
imaginables en una pandemia global china
quería demostrar que también con
coronavirus se pueden organizar unos
juegos con relativa normalidad pero hubo
de renunciar primero a los turistas
extranjeros y después a la venta de
entradas al público las 60.000 personas
que participarán los juegos entre
atletas periodistas o voluntarios
pasarán las próximas semanas en un
circuito cerrado con unos controles
estrictos sólo podrán quitarse la
mascarilla en sus dormitorios y
comedores y serán sometidos a una prueba
pcr diaria el objetivo no es tanto
evitar los contagios dentro de la
burbuja que se dan por descontados sino
que el virus no pase al resto de la
población el lema elegido es todos
juntos por un futuro en común y casi
todos estarán en beijing solo eeuu y
otros cuatro países que acostumbran a
alinearse con washington han aireado un
boicot diplomático que no deportivo
justicia en la política china en
xinjiang china ha lamentado la
politización del deporte y ha aclarado
que ese boicot simbólico no arruinará a
sus juegos